so I know I'm here for you to interview
me but I got I gotta ask about you
writing Simpsons and being staff on that
like yeah it's I just think did you did
you write full full episodes yeah and
just hand them in and go like that's
smart what happens is
um and this should be the whole
interview I think
Ed Sheeran talks to Conor O'Brien about
The Simpsons and I'm in heaven right now
that's what I want to know yeah yeah
okay I'll tell you all about it it is
funny because it is one of the now that
there's an internet there and the clips
are you know Clips circulate I can when
I travel around the world or if I travel
around the UK they can know me from
clips of Comedy clips from my show but
before that when I would go to the UK uh
they would not know who I was because a
lot of American talk shows weren't shown
there but they would know if the
Simpsons came up they would flip out and
they would ask me which episodes I
worked on and I would tell them and they
would be able to know all those they
would know everything because Simpsons
fans are everywhere well it was in in
England as well like it was we only
really had no one had cable so we had
BBC One BBC Two ITV and maybe channel
four right and BBC Two every day had two
episodes of The Simpsons so like you get
home from school and that would be the
thing you watch and it just like I get
but never I swear BBC only owns a couple
of Seasons because cause it was always
the same episode I'm like I see New
Seasons now and you never saw Bart get
older yeah it was I think we we stopped
we stopped at like season ten yeah my
kids love it well what's funny is that
um you know I was there uh I don't see
and my Simpsons fans know everything and
they get upset that I don't know it
because I was there and I was there you
know in a fairly early stage considering
how long it's run but we would watch the
episodes hundreds of times whereas you
probably just we would work on those
ones but uh yeah what would happen is
you would pitch a concept for an episode
so I would go and I'd say here's what I
think should happen and I would have all
these beats for an episode and ideas for
an episode and if they liked it they
would there was a little gong in the
room and they would you'd do this once a
year and uh they would literally if they
laughed in the the executive producer
was really laughing someone would get up
and bang the gong and say like that's
gonna be an episode and I remembered uh
the couple of times that they banged the
gong when I said my episode and I my
episodes and I was so excited were you
doing late night then or you went no oh
no God no no late night is you because
they stop I remember an episode where
they rip you on it and you're a late
late night yeah I saw me but yeah you
would come on it was an homage yeah
those are my friends they would never do
that to me
they're comedy writers are very kind
um no it's funny because uh yeah I was
working on The Simpsons and then uh for
a couple seasons and then I went to
audition for this late night show
thinking I'll never get this I'm a
writer on The Simpsons and then
tragically got it and uh that's how it
felt at the time like oh but I left
and was there ever part of you that just
like turned up at the Reuters room being
like can I Chuck in an idea every now
and then you know what's so funny I did
come back years later and the room is
not so many people think oh my God you
know this epic television show and this
known for its you know really good
writers and I'm just these people I got
to work with are insanely talented and
the room is just awful the room is
terrible it looks like the worst I mean
it did at the time I think it's much
nicer now but there was just a bad shag
carpet sofas that you know if you're at
your first year in college or university
and just get them on the sidewalk and we
would sit there and eat fried food there
was a writer that smoked all the time
who sat next to me so when I die it'll
be because of him and a big laugh gang
laugh it up
and we'd eat bad food and think and so
it wasn't sexy or fun or cool at all but
uh and and I remember we played it we
all chewed up some caramel and put it
together in a Big Blob and mashed it up
under the ceiling and then tried to get
things to stick to it because you'll do
anything to pass the time I love that
yeah well that's all the time we have
yeah
one of the best guests we've ever had